Joyeux anniversaire !
Maintenant, les gens,
ils disent plus bon anniversaire en vrai.
Ils te le disent
sur ton mur Facebook.
Et vu qu'écrire simplement "Joyeux anniversaire",
c'est un peu banal,
on dirait que chacun essaie de trouver
une formulation un petit peu originale,
de manière à être le pote
un peu plus cool que les autres.
[rires]
Il va trop se taper une barre !
Y en a même certains
qui écrivent HB,
l’abréviation
d'Happy Birthday.
Genre les mecs, ils ont même pas
le temps d'écrire le mot en entier, quoi !
Ouais, non, non,
tiens, mais attends,
là je suis un tout petit peu busy,
par contre, est-ce que, quitte pas !
HB ! On peut se faire un café si tu veux !
Cinq minutes, j'ai cinq minutes, là, si tu veux !
Des fois, à ton anniversaire, tes potes,
ils veulent t'organiser une fête surprise.
Ce qui est grave sympa, mais souvent
tu le sens un peu venir, quand même !
Eh les mecs, demain,
c'est mon anniversaire.
Peut-être qu'on pourrait
organiser une petite fête, non ?
Euh non,
moi je peux pas.
Ah moi, je peux pas, parce que j'ai un cancer
vite fait, du coup je vais aller à l'hosto.
Hé ! Ça va, ça fait longtemps !
Alors, qu'en fait...
Surprise !
♪ C'est la surprise ♪
Ah merci, je m'y
attendais pas du tout !
Faux !
C'est marrant, parce qu'on dirait
qu'en fonction de ton âge,
les gens se sentent obligés de faire
le commentaire de politesse obligatoire,
que tout le monde fait,
à chaque fois.
18 ans :
la majorité !
20 ans :
la vingtaine !
21 ans :
la majorité internationale !
25 ans :
un quart de siècle !
26 ans :
bah alors, ça y est, t'as 26 ans !
40 ans :
la dépression !
65 ans :
ça y est, c'est la retraite !
80 ans :
ça y est, bientôt, tu vas mourir !
À la tienne !
Quand la soirée
d'anniversaire bat son plein,
que les gens s'amusent,
qu'il y a une bonne ambiance,
tout d'un coup les lumières s'éteignent,
et alors là, on sait tous ce que ça veut dire.
Aaahh ! Le gâteau,
le gâteau, le gâteau !
Euh, pardon, c'est moi qui ait appuyé sans faire exprès,
avec mon coude. Je suis désolé.
Aaahh ! Le gâteau,
le gâteau !
Le gâteau !
Le gât—
Le gât— Le— Le—
Ah oui ! Un truc concernant les bougies
d'anniversaire qui se rallument toutes seules.
Heu, est-ce qu'il y a encore un mec
sur la planète Terre que ça fait rigoler ?
Allez, allez !
>> Ha ha ha !
Elles se sont rallumées, les bougies !
Non !
"Joyeux anniversaire", c'est vraiment
une chanson un peu beauf, tu vois,
un peu festive,
mais c'est ça qu'on aime.
Et moi, la dernière fois,
à mon anniversaire,
y a un mec qui voulait absolument
montrer qu'il savait bien chanter,
mais faut pas le faire
sur ce morceau-là,
les mecs, hein,
vraiment pas !
♪ Joyeux anniversaire ♪
Attends, en fait, je l'ai aussi en anglais.
Alors, je vous la fait.
Alors, je sais pas pourquoi, mais à chaque fois,
quand les bougies sont soufflées,
en général,
y a tout le monde qui crie
Un discours ! Un discours ! Un discours !
Moi, à ce moment-là,
je deviens hyper timide,
et le seul discours
que j'arrive à sortir, c'est
Hum, bah merci !
Ouais !!
Mais je me disais, les hommes politiques
qui font des discours toute la journée à la télé,
à ce moment-là, quand c'est leur anniversaire,
ils doivent être archi bons !
Si vous êtes là ce soir,
c'est parce que,
comme tous les Français,
vous voulez vous ambiancer
et vous avez raison.
On ne pense pas assez
à Kim ou Vanessa
qui ont gonflé les ballons un à un,
à la seule force de leurs poumons.
Merci à tous !
Quand t'ouvres tes cadeaux
devant tout le monde
et que tu reçois
un cadeau super nul, ça arrive,
c'est gênant, parce que t'es quand même
obligé de faire genre t'es content.
Ah ! Ah bah c'est un pull !
C'est un pull, bah moi...
C'est le même style que moi.
Ah ouais, ouais ! En plus, moi,
j'adore ce genre de pull !
J'ai déjà envie de le mettre !
Merci !
Franchement, les cadeaux d'anniversaire,
peu importe le prix,
t'as toujours le moyen de trouver
un truc cool, de faire des cadeaux fun,
et t'as toujours ce mec qui t'offre
ce cadeau qui te casse l'ambiance.
Ah ! Un livre !
>> T'es content ?
Ah merci !
>> C'est parce que je sais que t'aime bien lire.
En vrai, à ce moment-là,
t'aimerais trop faire
Ah ! Un livre ! Je m'en bats les couilles !
Cadeau suivant, merci !
>> Tiens !
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
En plus, le mec qui t'offre un livre,
en général,
il aime bien commencer à te raconter ce qu'il y a dedans,
histoire de justifier son cadeau moyen,
alors que franchement,
c'est pas le moment !
Tu vas voir,
c'est super intéressant,
parce que ça raconte l'histoire
de la Bataille de Verdun.
Attends, attends, alors,
plus précisément, l'histoire d'un soldat.
Attends, parce que c'est super intéressant,
la mère est belge mais son père était français.
Ah ouais !
Les mecs qui ont pas acheté de cadeau,
en général, ils disent toujours
Bon alors, par contre,
moi, j'ai pas de cadeau.
Là, je l'ai pas pour l'instant, mais là,
je vais t'en acheter un mardi ou mercredi.
Normalement, tu vas l'avoir
vers samedi à peu près.
OK !
>> Voilà !
Joyeux anniversaire !
Cela veut dire que
tu ne l'auras jamais !
Quoi qu'il en soit,
cadeau ou pas cadeau,
quand c'est notre anniversaire,
ça fait toujours plaisir qu'on nous le souhaite.
Alors, si aujourd'hui, c'est le vôtre,
je tenais à vous le dire, joyeuses Pâques !
Si vous êtes là ce soir,
c'est parce que vous voulez vous ambiancer,
et vous avec ha ha ha !
Merci pour ces cadeaux, c'est grave cool !
>> Ouais, avec plaisir !